I'm Flaminio Kathy Rita I'm associate
professor at the Harvard th Chan School
of Public Health and today I'm going to
give a lecture on vector biology and the
dynamics of malaria transmission the
lecture is divided in five chapters in
the first chapter I'll talk about the
complexity of mosquito biology and how
that influences malaria transmission in
the second chapter I look at the journey
of the Plasmodium parasites within the
mosquito in the third chapter I'll
introduce the concept of vector capacity
which is the interaction of the
biological processes that are important
for transmission in Chapter four I'll
discuss current methods that are
available for mosquito control while in
Chapter five I'll discuss austerity
strategies that might become available
in the near future and might take us to
malaria eradication let me start with
chapter one and describe the complex
mosquito biology and how that influences
money transmission malaria is
transmitted to humans exclusively by
mosquitoes of the anopheles genus there
are about 500 Anopheles pieces in the
world
however only 30 to 40 are considered
important vectors of human malaria this
species has spread throughout the globe
as seen here in this slide and they have
very different behaviors during larval
and other stages during larval
development which lasts about seven to
ten days
mosquitoes are adapted to very different
ecological habitats some mosquito
species for instance prefer breeding in
temporary breeding sites such as those
provided by rain puddles while others
would prefer breathing in permanent
building sites such as rice fields some
mosquitoes are highly adapted to
saltwater and so live in coastal areas
while other mosquitoes can only survive
in freshwater
these different ecological habitats
exposed mosquitoes to different
environments for instance different
temperature conditions and temperature
shifts between day and night also
different microorganisms predators and
nutritional reserves
interns the ecological habitats which
these mosquitoes are exposed as larvae
will impact the physiology of adults
emerging from those building sites with
possible consequences for manual
transmission for instance larvae that
are adapted to temporary sites may have
reduced availability of nutrients and
may have a shorter developmental time so
the adults emerging from those breeding
sites
will generally be smaller in size and
that might need to feed more often as
adults on blood in order to meet the
energetic demands of flying made in
reproducing and so on this in turn might
create more opportunities for Plasmodium
parasites for their own transmissions
because a mosquito that much more often
obviously will be more capable of
transmitting malaria let's take a look
at the mosquito life cycle starting from
male and female adults imagine from
pupae after imagine males and females
we'll have to find each other in order
to mate so that the female can become
inseminated with sperm transferred by
the male then the female will have to go
and look for a host for a blood meal and
after taking a blood meal she will rest
for a couple of days during which time
she will digest the blood components and
incorporate them into the developing
eggs after developing the eggs the
female will use the sperm that she's
received by the males to fertilize those
eggs and then she laid them in suitable
of a position sites the eggs that are
laid will then hatch into larvae and the
larvae will undergo four developmental
stages before transforming into pupae
from well then male and female adults
will emerge and the cycle will continue
blood feeding is really an essential
component in the mosquito life cycle and
it's a step in which mosquitoes from
different species exhibit quite a
variety of behaviors for instance some
mosquito species are highly adapted to
feeding on humans so they are highly
untrue prophetic while other mosquito
species predominantly feed on animals
such as birds or cows or rats in order
to transmit malaria to humans mosquitoes
will have to have a certain degree of
entrepot philia because they will need
to feed on humans at least twice a first
time they'll have to buy a person that
is infected with malaria parasites and
they'll ingest those parasites and then
after a few days when spore Golikov
development is completed then the
mosquito will inject those parasites
into the next human being the propensity
of a mosquito to feed on humans rather
than animals can actually be measured
and this is the so called human blood
index the human blood index can be
measured by collecting mosquitoes in the
field and looking at the content of
their blood to see what is from animal
or from human origin this value goes
from 0 to 1 with 0 being mosquitoes that
feed exclusively on animals so highly
sulfuric and 1 with mosquitoes that feed
on
on humans so highly on top of it as you
can see in this map there is height
originally I'm almost kiddoes for the
human blood index and many mosquito
species with a high level of
entropically actually cluster in Africa
and these mosquitoes belong to
mosquitoes of the anopheles gambiae
complex such as an affluent Gambia and
offers Cloutier but also an office phone
Estes which is another very important
factor of human malaria in Africa
mosquitoes with a high level of on top
affiliate also found in Papua New Guinea
like an awful for LT as well as in South
America even if to a lesser extent like
an office darling I in any given area
there might be multiple and awful
species that live in sympathy and this
might complicate control measures for
instance let's have a look at Africa and
oddly enough has gamba complex this
complex comprises eight mosquito species
that are morphologically identical and
can only be distinguished at the
molecular level these pieces include
some of the most important mother
vectors such as nostrils Gambian offers
Arabian Sasan Donovan's Colucci eye as
well as some of more minor vectors like
an officer Marys and Maris which are
adapted to coastal areas because they
prefer breathing in soft water also the
complex includes some species that are
not considered vectors of human malaria
such as an office quadrant lattice
because they tend to by predominantly on
animals if you look at the major malar
vectors and off less Gambian an awful
school UTI this until recently were
believed to be the same species and just
different molecular forms and office
gambia was previously known as an office
can be as form while another exclusive a
was previously known as an office Gambia
and form an office Gambian office gluts
a very similar biting behavior because
they both tend to feed on humans and
late at night and indoors
however they show quite different
ecological habitus during level
developments Anopheles gambiae tend to
prefer living in temporary building
sites such as rain puddles while
unlawful is Colucci I prefer living in
permanent building sites such as rice
fields we don't know yet whether these
two species contribute differently to
manage transmission an officer audiences
is a third important malaria vector that
shares habitats with an office Gambon
roses Colucci I until recently this
mosquito species was not considered to
be a very important back to for you
malaria because these mosquitoes also
feed on animals apart from humans and so
they dilute potential infectious bites
however because of their plastic
behavior and the fact that these
mosquitoes can feed outdoors and wrestle
doors apart from feeding arrested
indoors these mosquitoes become more
difficult to be controlled with current
vector control strategies and so in
recent years that become more and more
relevant for malaria transmission when
multiple mosquito species live in
sympathy it becomes really difficult to
understand the relative contribution to
Maya transmission this is well explained
in this study by Fontanella Dahl
conducted in 1997 in a small village in
Senegal called Gelman what yours did
they looked at the relative contribution
of three important malaria vectors and
awfulest Gambia and Officer ambiances
and office phone Estes over the course
of three years it is important to note
that at that time an office Gambia were
considered to be a single species well
now we know that those pieces contain
both on first camera and analyst Colucci
I what he also states they collected
mosquitoes from this village
and then they analyzed their salary
glands to look for the presence of
spores ways of promoting falserum
and after this analysis what they could
determine is that enough rest can be
mosquitoes were a very important vector
in year one while instead a contribution
decline in year two it was negligible in
year three well enough lesser Arabian
seas had almost the opposite pattern the
were a negligible vector in year one are
will be more important in year two and
much more relevant in year three what
analysts finesses as a sort of an
intermediate pattern and the word
unimportant Latin in year one also
during the dry season because these
mosquitoes are better adapted to dry
conditions they sort of disappeared
during yet - and they came back strongly
in year three this study is a good
example the complexity of malaria
transmission even in a small village and
prior to any vector control intervention
as it was back then and also shows
importance of performing longitudinal
studies across a number of years looking
at all possible mosquito species that
might be contributing to minor
transmission
you